all right good so all right so yeah
welcome everyone to a workshop on the
Simons workshop on learning algorithm
design and and beyond worst case
analysis zelgius heads jointly organized
by near island inna Balkan myself Ravi
Kumar Kevin Leighton Brown and tim
roughgarden so just a and Oscar said so
this workshop is part of this Simon's
semester program on algorithms and
uncertainty at the Simon Institute for
the theory of computing and I just want
to make a few notes
Elster covered some of these so again no
food or drinks in the auditorium sorry
mention about the wireless at the end of
each day except for Wednesday we have
some time for short and prompt to talks
I've got some of you have talked to me
already if you're interested in giving
an impromptu talk just come talk to me
we still have room for a few more so Kai
email me or just talk to me in person
and we'll schedule you as Alistair said
there's a reception after the talks
today in addition to that we also have
set up some optional social events each
evening you probably got email from
Kevin so after the wine tease reception
will head over to a micro brew pub
nearby for some more discussion Tuesday
we had like a game night we reserved a
few more spots then then the number of
people who said yes so so there's still
a little room if you're interested in
coming just you know you can you can
come along there's still still a few
extra spots Wednesday well the trip to
San Francisco after the talks Thursday
another micro brew pub whichever one we
didn't go to when we didn't go to on
Monday and Friday some place with great
Indian Street food that will head off
okay good so that's it for its of the
preliminaries so I wanted to do now is
just give kind of a brief tour of
theoretical models and algorithm
analysis beyond the worst-case so so
first of all what's the issue so the
issue is that you take a problem like
you know network flow or traveling
salesman or graph coloring or sat it
consists of a family of instances not
just one is that's a whole whole family
and you know any given algorithm might
do better on some and worse on others
and traditionally you know our goal is
we'd like an algorithm it performs well
on all instances in the family that's
that's worst-case analysis we'd really
like an elegant works well on any
instance and in the family of problems
and and it's great if we can get it we
can do it it's wonderful for a lot of
reasons I mean one is then you don't
need to worry about the instance
structure you can use it for reductions
without worrying about what they're
gonna look like so you know Network flow
and your programming algorithms you get
good albums for that now you can just
take other problems convert them into
network flow or linear programming and
run them without really worrying what
they're gonna exactly look like also we
could've have a feel that we cracked the
problem if we have an algorithm that
does well you know on all instances in
the family what's the problem is that
you know sometimes we can't do it you
know there are these problems that are
so intrinsically are in the worst case
and so kind of a first classical
approach around this is a look at
average case analysis you know look at
random instances so-so ran so average
case is less pessimistic and it can
often give some insight into the problem
you may be you have an algorithm that
you know if you kind of think of
conceptually as instances being along
the x axis that on you know some cases
it runs really slowly as a bad worst
case found the maybe on the on most
cases it works well and has a much
better average case bill and so
historically a lot of work and just
highlight just a couple of things so
beard weather at all 1959's actually was
structural than algorithmic but the game
of princes a tight analysis of the
length of the optimal TSP tour four
random points drawn in a bounded region
in the plane say like the unit square
and that was used by dick carp and not
77 to give an algorithm that's impala
optimal algorithm for the average case
for travelling salesmen there's a really
great classic result so right so so we
can we can you know do a lot better on
average of course the problem is that in
any many cases random is not always the
same as is typical right so to the left
is a random image and to the right is a
typical image and and they're not the
same right been looking at a lot of cat
images so you know also the other thing
is that random instances are also often
in a kind of a bizarre way very specific
so for instance if you think about say a
random 3 colorable graph then it's going
to have a lot of it's got a little kind
of like a particular graph it's gonna
have a lot of structure for example two
nodes of the same color well almost all
share about the same number of neighbors
in common and two nodes of different
color while almost all share about half
that many neighbors in common and so
kind of this is a you know it's it's of
a very particular kind of thing all kind
of all the random graphs kind of look
the same in some sense so so this sort
of thing this kind of issue of in the
worst case you know great if you can get
it but any problems you can't versus the
average case of random not being same as
typical lead to sieve a flurry of work
in the 1990s on intermediate models so
actually I structure this kind of good
to a decade by decade of kind of a
sampling of models and results so the
intermediate models between average case
and worst case and in particular with
focus on np-hard problems that are hard
to approximate well because the offline
setting and also online problems with
high
competitive ratios in the online zone so
actually once so one fun thing about
doing this talk gives me a chance to
look at some again at some old papers
and I thought I'd start with one of mine
so this is a paper from Fox 1990 and so
this paper was it was in part about a
worst-case approximation algorithms for
a three coloring problem but in addition
it proposed an intermediate model and so
it says you know we also illustrate
these techniques by considering a
problem where the three chromatic graph
is created not by a worst-case adversary
but instead in the adversary where each
decision of whether to put in an edge or
not is flipped with some small
probability or noise rate P so you know
you've got an adversary with the shaky
hand trying to construct this graph and
the decisions that reverse with some
small probability P and so if you set P
to 1/2 you get the truly random model
you set P to 0 you get the fully
adversarial model and in between what
you get is you can get graphs that have
some structure to them but nonetheless
have enough randomness you can recover
the 3-coloring in this particular paper
you handled P down to roughly 1 over
root n following that a fyg and Killian
showed the right way to solve this
problem using semi definite programming
is in a really nice way and they they
gave algorithms for K coloring and
independent set for very low down to the
basically the best possible noise rate P
you could handle using a really nice
algorithm they also point out that you
know you can make the model a little
more adversarial even so for instance
all the algorithms you can assume the
noise only adds edges noise it takes
away I did that that don't doesn't hurt
that doesn't cause it's not making
problem any harder so you can assume the
noise only adds edges in fact you can
assume the adversary sees all the coin
flips in advance and all the algorithms
will still work and so from that
perspective you can think of the model
in a different way you can think of it
as starting with a sparse random graph
at the adversary then just adds edges
- you can view it that way say between
the different colors or from the
independence set to its complement and
then they also had results for bisection
in a related model and effect we'll see
today some talks or I've been done well
Vijay Raghavan will talk about recent
results in graph partitioning and models
like this and where if I go we'll talk
about a model where this randomness is
replaced but by deterministic expansions
you don't even need randomness as long
as the graph has some expansion
properties so I've been parallel to this
in the world of online algorithms it was
this issue was also in the air in the
90s and a lot of work on going beyond
worst-case analysis models in online
algorithms so in online algorithms first
of all the setting so an algorithm is
faced with a request sequence Sigma some
sequence of requests maybe page requests
or different kind of requests and you
have to make decisions like oh you're
going to evict the page or what to do
without knowing the future and one looks
there at competitive ratio which is the
analog of approximation ratio for online
algorithms how well is your algorithm
doing what's its cost divided by the
optimal cost worst case over sequences
of events that might happen so for
instance in paging worst case over
requests sequences for pages of the
ratio of how much your algorithm is
paying in terms of page faults over the
optimal that would be the the
competitive ratio and what in in
analyzing this what was notice for
problems like paging so in paging the
best possible deterministic ratio is K
which is the number of pages in the in
the fast memory and it's achieved both
by kind of good algorithms that people
use like LRU and kind of bad algorithms
people don't use like FIFO
I mean not by really bad obviously
people don't use fight when they use LRU
and the question was you know can you
explain what makes LRU better sometimes
this this worst case was too crude to
sort of explain what makes LRU better
can you bypass the lower bound
so this led to in 91 Borodin Iran Iran
Schieber defined an access graph model
what they said was where the page
requests come from they come from
computer programs accessing memory and
computer programs often have a graph
structure like you know maybe this this
this thing is going into a loop and it
kind of goes around the lobe maybe bike
passes it a little bit man kind of comes
out and so you can think of a computer
program as defining a graph on pages
where the accesses are restricted to
walks on that graph it maybe that helps
in thinking that way so in fact they
analyzed the competitive ratio of LRU as
a function of properties of the graph
and they show that it's never much worse
than FIFO and can be a lot better
depending on structural properties of
the graph and then they also designed an
interesting near optimal algorithm if
your algorithm actually gets access to
the graph so if LRU doesn't look at the
graph but if you look at then you could
do some other things around the same
time Neil Young gave a really neat model
of this lose competitiveness model which
addressed a different issue which is you
can look at the lower bounds in online
algorithms for paging they have the
following property you give me an
algorithm you give me a K I'll give you
a bad sequence but maybe you can have an
algorithm that for any sequence for most
K it works well it's only a few weird
bad K where K is the size of the fast
memory in which case you know as long as
the the request sequence the program is
not colluding with the hardware you know
then then maybe you know it makes sense
talk about what you're doing on most
okay and this was the idea of loose
competitiveness and there were a series
of other models Markov paging so like
access craft that's a Markov chain the
fewest adversary model of gusu pious and
papademetriou was also came out shortly
after where you think of the request
sequence is drawn from some distribution
over sequences coming from some known
class and then you can talk about how
competitive ratio is a function of
class of distributions so there's also a
lot of work there and I want to mention
one more thing in the 90s which is in
parallel all this work and learning
theory and this is like a in some sense
of a worst case model but I want to view
it as I'm in-between or as a kind of
intermediate model and I'll tell you why
so this is the problem of combining
expert advice and the setting so the
setting here is you have a collection of
actions like which way should I Drive to
work each day and the problem is that
which one is best is it's totally
different each day like traffic is just
different each day let's say there's no
way to predict just traffic is it
different each day and that's the way it
is so you know you have to get to work
and so we need to pick away and then you
know it might or might not be the best
and so when you look back in hindsight
in hindsight well maybe you should have
done path a on day one and then little
traffic was different on day two you
should have done path B then and then
day three was more like day one you
should have taken path a on that day and
and so on right now when you look back
you're just gonna go crazy if you try to
compete with that because there's no way
to compete with the best in hindsight
shoes on this and that and this madness
and that right but how about just trying
to compete with the best fixed single
path so a worst-case sequence of events
of truck traffic times we can't tell
what's gonna happen day to day but just
try to compete with the best single path
and the reason why I'm saying this is an
intermediate model is that the
motivation here is motivationally if the
world was iid if each day traffic was an
independent draw from a distribution
over traffic patterns and you know each
day God goes in the bucket and says this
is what traffic doesn't be like that day
okay then the best thing to do would be
in looking forward would be to pick the
path with the best expectation just use
that every single day right I mean that
would minimize the expected cost you
picked the past the best expected cost
so if the world was iid the best thing
would be a single path from with the
best expectation and so this model says
it's a worst-case sequence but we're
competing with the best strategy in a
restricted class that includes the
optimal for the iid Senate
so in that sense it's kind of an
intermediate model worst-case sequence
but competing with respect to the best
strategy in a smaller class motivated by
the iid sin so now let me so going to
the two thousands a kind of maybe a the
sort of a perspective change that
happened although we saw that in the 90s
as well was a real interest in
understanding the observed success of
practical algorithms and really the
canonical example of this is the smooth
analysis model of Spielman in time so
the smooth analysis model as you have an
input typically of saying it's
unweighted graph or it's a matrix or
something and then every entry is
perturbed with a small amount of
Gaussian noise so now if you have an
algorithm that say performs really well
most innocent but but but really badly
on a few isolated Peaks that gets
smoothed out it's basically convolve
with the gaussian that produce a picture
more like this in terms of running time
and what they proved was in fact so you
can think of this as little bit like the
semi random model except instead of
binary decisions at a flip to some
probability it's it's numerical
decisions where each one has a little
bit of Gaussian noise what they proved
was at the simplex algorithm which we
know in the worst case can take
exponential time runs in polynomial time
an expectation for any instance if you
add a little bit of random noise so in
some sense this is you know the bad
cases have to be very particular you had
a little bit of random noise and then
all of a sudden we get polynomial
expected time which was really nice
so so that was great and I should say
that in a certain formal session at
least for the kinds of problems that one
looks at this tends to be a more
adversarial model than the semi-random
model so that for instance if you have a
problem that's hard to approximate some
of the analysis is not going to really
help because in almost all and all the
problems of interest in a in an optimum
solution in a perturbed model is an
approximately optimal solution in the
original problem so right so you take
something you perturb it solve it
optimally it can be approximately
optimal in the original so the problem
is hard to approximate this is not going
to help but nonetheless before for
easier problems it can potentially take
an algorithm like simplex that we
observe to do really well and say hey
you know that these worst case you know
it really does the worst cases are very
particular right and so then there was a
lot of work on this I just mentioned a
few like the to op TSP heuristic lloyd's
k-means algorithm a lot of really nice
work on smooth analysis now actually
both of these problems TSP and k-means
are hard to approximate in the worst
case so these results are for time to
reach a local optimum you know the
smooth analysis is is too adversarial to
to really talk about reaching a global
optimum for these kind of problems but
nonetheless can talk about quickly
reaching a local optimum
so that actually the segue to kind of
mean go to the late-2000s we're okay if
we want to talk about reaching a global
optimum then we're gonna need to make
some more assumptions we're this is not
enough it's too adversarial and so this
led to a lot of work on models of nice
inputs we're placing typically replacing
randomness with deterministic conditions
where the goals here could have to
understand whether reasonable with a
nice inputs look like what properties of
an instance make it easy or hard to find
a global global optimum or or a desired
solution and we use implicit assumptions
and problem formulations and can we
explain the success of common
so so so continuing my torso so a really
influential paper on these lines is this
work of Ostrovsky Rabbani Shulman and
Swami looking at the particular problem
of k-means clustering so k-means
clustering something people do as all
the time you have a bunch of data you're
trying to cluster into into groups and
and k-means is a particular strategy
particular objective function that that
that is commonly used and and so what is
the objective function so so you're
trying to cluster this let's say we
tried the cluster this into three
clusters even though it obviously looks
like it should be four but let's say we
did three and the cost okay so so
k-means clustering is is you know you
grew up in two clusters in each one you
have a center this little X and the cost
is the sum of the squares of distances
of points to the center of their cluster
alright so for all these dots here you
add up the sum of the squares of the
distances to that X and that's the cost
all right so that's k-means cost and one
kind of obvious fact about k-means is
that the cost of the optimal k-means
clustering decreases with k if you're
allowed okay if you allow more clusters
you're going to get smaller cost because
you gives you more more centers until
finally K is n then the cost is zero
because you have to look every point so
okay right with that so so right so for
three you get this and most of the cost
is coming from here if you had four you
could you could split that and have you
know two centers and now you have a
smaller cost and so in practice like how
do you pick a K anyway well one way is
you often choose a K base all sort of
knee in the curve you so look at the
cost and you graph it with K that goes
down down down then maybe it flattens
out and maybe that flattening out where
the kind of knee and the curve is a good
choice of K it's often a nice practical
heuristic for that and what Ostrovsky
Dahl showed was that if you're you know
your app you're kind of on the downslope
if the optimal solution for K clusters
is really much cheaper than the optimal
solution for K minus one clusters so you
go from kms one the K and the
drops by significant factor so it's
significantly cheaper by you know it's
only a epsilon squared times what the
cost was then a natural heuristic will
actually find you a near optimal
solution so that was really nice and
then later with pranzo Awasthi and/or
chef I we were able to sort of improve
that guarantee to say well little s you
don't quite need that that steep but you
just need to be smaller by some caustic
like you know ninety percent doesn't
have to be you know there could be nine
times off K minus one you can still get
1 plus epsilon but but this didn't
didn't use the natural heuristic and he
is a special purpose
so then what kind of related but but too
motivated by machine learning
considerations came to in 2009 and 2010
two models that have their kind of
really motivated by thinking of
clustering as a machine learning problem
and looking at how input is collected
and how the output of the clustering
algorithm is is typically used and in
particular these models approximation
stability and perturbation resilience
are based on ik an observation that for
clustering and other problems to but in
particular for clustering was one
canonical thing but but they're also
useful in a this happens in other kinds
of problems as well the often the true
goal is to match a desired solution you
care about kind of accuracy and matching
some some target some desired solution
and the objective you're using like
k-means is just something you can
measure as a proxy for that so what do I
mean what I mean well like maybe you're
giving us a news articles and what you'd
like to do you know your Google you have
the news articles you want to cluster
them in a way a user would like but you
can't measure how you're doing with
respect to that instead you put them as
points in space and you minimize
something like k-means cost but you
really want to do is you know do it the
way the user would like or given a set
of images cluster by who is in them so
here there is like a well-defined right
answer okay you know the these these are
one person this is another person and
you know you put these as points at
space or something and you know that's
what you really want to do is match
accuracy watching a lot of sorry
nightlife to okay so or given a picture
segmented into objects is a well-defined
kind of ground truth there that's your
real goal but your algorithm doesn't get
to see that so I has to optimize
something else some proxy objective okay
and so right so here here's the key
point the objective your algorithm is
optimizing like k-means score is a
measurable proxy for some goal that you
really care about the can't measure of
accuracy and so this motivate of these
models so for instance the the model of
approximation stability
let me just is the following so see
epsilon approximation stability we say
an instance satisfies this stability
condition if it has the following
property that any C approximation to the
objective you're using would get you
Absalon close to the solution you want
okay we give you you know high accuracy
only make an epsilon you know fraction
of the objects may be clustered the
wrong way so this is an assumption and
instance Michael might not satisfy but
if it satisfies this any C approximation
is epsilon close then by assumption if
you had a C approximation you would get
a solution its epsilon close because you
just assumed that and the question is
you know can you use this to get the
order epsilon close when you don't have
a C approximation
okay so just the thing I want to make
clear here is that the answer this
question is obviously yes if you have a
C approximation because by assumption
you're saying that any C approximation
to the objective is going to be close to
what you're looking for so if you had an
algorithm that guarantees you this it
would also give you that but maybe this
assumption could be used to get close to
the reference without necessarily having
the C approximation element so the
picture that you want to keep in mind
like this so if you think about this is
like solution space and this is cost
space the optimal solution is sitting
here desired solution is there the
optimum may or may not be exactly the
same is the desired solution may be the
k-means often is slightly off but not
too far off and the assumption is if you
go up by some amount
that everything that below the optimum
is closed could be some things they're
closed they're not good score but that
the dis dis should be small width right
and anything far away should be more
expensive and then what this work joint
with Nina Balkan on a pom Gupta showed
is that for a number of clustering
objectives K median k-means min some the
answer is yes even for values of C like
one point one where we don't have C
approximations in fact it's np-hard and
then there's there was a subsequent work
for inter vivos skeeball Conrado and
tang and Chia gave a really super fast
algorithms with a small number of
distance queries where you you have to
you know you're not given up front the
distance matrix small number of distance
queries I was motivated by biological
settings where you can do certain kind
of blast queries and then they they
showed you could use that to get this
kind of guarantee and actually get good
results for biological sequence
and also work on Nash equilibria another
setting where you might might look at so
on the other side the model of
perturbation resilience this is looking
at the input side of the equation so in
the input sides would be little and
lineal suggestions as the following so
if you look at these kind of problems
you know you're taking these objects
like images and putting them as points
in space or as nodes say no it's in a
weighted graph with edge lengths it
depends on some notion of distance
between them what is the distance
between these two images you know the
somme algorithm it's somehow is taking
these objects putting them as as nodes
in some graph
defining some kind of distance is it the
correct is it like it's not like
distance it's not like how you know
walking distance it's some measure it's
somewhat heuristic what the distance is
between these two images and so if your
algorithm say that optimized k-means
happened to work well it happened to
give you the right answer and it's small
changes to that distance definition
radically change the answer to where the
optimum say k-means score is then you
know if it happens to matter you're
looking for it's kind of by luck right
so because because it was kind of a
there was no like obvious correct answer
to what the distance should be so if
small changes the distance has really
moved around the optimal solution you
don't really have a lot of confidence
that it's gonna you know you're gonna be
so lucky that you happen to make the
right guess if you're s tick distance
but the matching thing you're looking
for so they proposed is this idea that
let's say input is alpha perturbation
resilient if you take the input and
changing the input values like the
distance is by up to some factor alpha
it doesn't change the optimal solution
according to your objective and in the
basic definition doesn't change it at
all although there's been work on
allowing it to change a little bit so
let's assume the instance has that
property it's kind of nicely stable you
modify distances a bit and the optimum
solution doesn't change can we use that
can we use that to actually find the
optimum solution
and and I just to mention the connection
it's generally harder than approximation
stability for the same parameter setting
so in particular here's the thing for
almost all of these problems an optimal
solution to the perturbed instance is an
approximately optimal solution in the
original instance you take the things
you modify the distance a little bit
solve optimally that's gonna be
approximately optimal solution to the
original but doesn't go the other way
around
you could have an approximately optimal
solution in the original it's not
optimal for any perturbation okay and
because of that this is a harder model
because you're assuming less you're
assuming about optimal solutions and
perturbed instances which is less than
assuming about approximately optimal
solutions in the original because of
that many it's just a harder model and
many of the results need stability above
the approximation bound which in the
case of approximation stability would be
kind of obvious you know because it's
just by definition right you can do that
the interesting case there is below the
approximation down here often you know
it's interesting even above the
approximation that's just a harder model
but they've been a lot of really nice
work
in some cases they coincide so in case
of Nash equilibria of all kind braverman
show the two definitions are identical
okay they're really the same this has
been a lot of work a lot of results
starting with max cut a lot of really
nice work on max cut Nash equilibria TSP
comedian k-means problems Kay Center
including the asymmetric case which is
interesting because you can go actually
substantially below the approximation
down there and we'll see a talk today on
that in a multi-way cut and and others
and I me also just highlight some
related work cochon West Samadhi and Ben
Eden and they on the Peshawar and Ben
devide on it on related models assume
even a little bit less and if we're
clustering and we
sighs give me talk fine I don't know if
it's on these results or in something
else like that and let me just end by
talking about one other really
interesting model and then we'll see uh
talks to Wednesday about that here which
is average case for an unknown
distribution so going back to our
concern with the usual average case
analysis this problem that random is
different from typical so how do we deal
with that well one way to deal with that
is what about looking an average case
over the distribution of typical
instances for your application so rather
than looking at like truly random images
look at random images found on the web
right we're at random TSP instances not
for uniform and the plane but for the
kinds of things that your application is
dealing with that would make sense you
know that then then you wouldn't have
this problem
because it's by definition you're
looking at random over typical things
and so how can one talk about that so
you can think of an algorithm it's like
really a machine learning algorithm
given as input a collection of random
samples of typical instances instances
drawn from say some distribution that
has to do with your application and then
the goal of your learning algorithm
would be from them to somehow learn the
best algorithm or best algorithm from
some given family of natural natural
algorithms for your applications
distribution I think is a really
interesting direction we'll see several
talks on this on on Wednesday just
briefly mentioned so so so some work and
the first work along these lines work on
sorting and problems in computational
geometry by eye launches al Clarke's and
William Osler and Seshadri is the
collective journal version of a
collection of conference papers looking
at sorting and and delaney triangulation
and convex hull and there they assume a
product distribution on the items within
the input but they really compete with
so the information through either
Gotham as work on revenue maximizing
auctions where you assume that bidders
have some valuation distribution which
is a natural assumption there but you
don't want to assume you know the
distribution in advance your algorithms
gonna go just get samples and how well
you know can you use the samples to act
as if you knew the distribution and then
most recently work on some general
algorithmic problems the work of Gupta
and roughgarden and Vulcan and Rajah and
the turkic and white looking at the case
we just have a general with any problem
no prior assumption on what that
distribution over instances is but we
will do is we'll just we rather than
competing with any algorithm at all will
compete with algorithms the best
algorithm from a given natural family so
you might have a natural family of
heuristics that people use and come and
compete with the best algorithm in that
families all right so let me just end by
saying okay so coming up so coming up
we'll see some theoretical talks on
algorithms and models some of the ones I
talked about and some and other ones I
will see empirical talks on approaches
in practice and experiments we'll see
application talks on properties of
real-world inputs and various domains
and I think it should be a lot of fun
so take questions or if it's just like
survey that I guess yeah
I'm just curious why didn't you discuss
things probably tractability at all I
mean isn't that another fairly obvious
approach for going beyond worst-case
analysis sure I mean so the question was
what about fixed parameter tractability
that's that's that's an excellent I mean
partly I just I just picked some things
and you're right so a fixed parameter
tractability let me just mention is it's
the worst case but it's looking at it's
looking at more fine-grained so for
example if you're gonna look at you know
maybe a problem like vertex cover or
something you know or just oh it's a
good say say k-means clustering you know
you could look at when the k value is
small or you could look at when when
some parameters are small and then maybe
you get good algorithms right for those
cases so that's what it writes about a
lot of really nice work on that I just I
just picked something but it's a great
thing to point out fixed parameter
tractability a lot of my sort
but I think the motivation is different
Thank You fixed-parameter we're trying
to see what makes the algorithm run fast
and feel there's more motivation is
natural English but you can take those
results and say I completely see this
point I just feel that sometimes people
that do fixed parameter tractability
sell it by saying well you know maybe
these naturally occurring families of
instances can you reasonably well
described by bounding the father for
instance and that's my certain natural
algorithms run well and I always found
this pretty compelling so I was
interested whether there is something
I'm missing here whether you know there
is a reason to dismiss that argument no
III agree in fact right many of these
like if you look at like the access
graph for instance for the online you
know there's a parameter in there that
that paper will that's tooth number of
articulation though is that that's right
so yeah I think many of these another
direction in terms of this which is at
some level the whole point of you know
the limitations of worst-case analysis
let's try to understand how algorithms
are working in practice but there's the
other side of it you take the analysis
and get better algorithms in practice is
there any focus in this work on power in
this whole range of things we're
actually taking the theoretical
algorithms we're coming out of these
different models and trying to see what
they do back in practice on real-world
instances that people care about all
right so I mean I think that that's a
that's a great point to think so about
you know do the models that the
algorithm suggested by the models useful
in practice and I I think there's
certainly been some interest you know
it's it's one of the things where you
know as a theoretician you're typically
just it mostly interested in the theory
and then you know but but in fact in
some cases right so you can find that so
so there are certainly cases like the
one I know is this one of approximation
stability from biological sequence
clustering so they are the issue as
you don't actually see the distances you
have this thing that this is blast is
that that given the point can get
estimate distances around what would be
a good algorithm to use how do you do
what like what metric in some sense many
of these define metrics yard sticks and
so what they said was let's look at this
as a yardstick designing algorithm for
that and then test it out now and they
found that got got good results now
could you have gotten equally good
results had you used a different yar
sake it's hard to tell but at least I
think in some cases what these do is
they give you interesting different
yardstick so you know approximation
ratio was one yardstick these often give
you other ones and then they just give
you other ways to think that maybe allow
you to expand what you're thinking yeah
but that's that's a great a great point
do they you know that we we should be
doing I'll just mention one other thing
that I might have included which is
resource augmentation and online
algorithms right I think is they're very
successful in allowing thinking about
comparing your offline algorithm to an
online algorithm it has slightly more
resources and it gets exactly at
something you brought up that the the
worst case instances are not shouldn't
be tuned to say the speed of a machine
and write this exactly helps you explain
that and explain yeah that's a great
point so a resource augmentation so you
can kind of think of it as by criteria
where you have you know or if you have a
little bit more resources that thing
you're comparing to maybe you know using
K K pages in their cache you can do
nearly as well as the optimum using you
know it has a few a little bit less in
fact the original Slater Tarjan paper
had that you know and and and so right
so absolutely so that's another another
really a very very fruitful all right so
the stay on time I should probably end
here and we ran low BJ Arvin that'll be
next